in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape and he's not
afraid to be our guest in the studio
today welcome professor d300
cardiologist from berlin hello when a
patient suffer a heart attack usually
there's some obstruction going on in the
coronary arteries and with the broken
heart syndrome the coronaries are clear
but the symptoms seem to be the same
how's that well the symptoms are similar
are identical the cause is different
namely the occlusion the blocked a
coronary artery by its rhombus on the
one side for the heart attack on the
other side it's shrinking contracting of
the RV of the vessels but the results
are the same namely that the heart
master doesn't become it does get enough
oxygen and therefore it doesn't pump as
as it should and this is the same
situation in heart attack and the same
situation in a broken heart syndrome the
symptoms are similar can a patient
distinguish between a heart attack and a
broken heart syndrome you're not and the
doctor as well you cannot and if you if
you get a call as a well I feel chesta
might when I was a paid on my chest and
so you cannot differentiate you cannot
distinguish between heart attack pain
and no pain due to broken heart syndrome
thus the answer is clear you have to go
immediately to the hospital and they
will decide by a catheterization what is
heart attack or a broken heart syndrome
and sometimes our heart attack can be
fatal broken heart syndrome can be fatal
as well as well because the problem is
the fatality is that you abruptly can
get arrhythmias ventricular fibrillation
so the hardest
suddenly stand still then you collapse
and will die immediately if nobody is
there for resuscitation so the the
outcome of the patient could be the same
but how can you treat it I mean it's a
cardiologist with heart attack you can
just put a stent into it a catheter and
then dilate the arteries but how can you
treat broken heart syndrome well in
patient with Bogaerts and Robbie are
happy because we know that in
ninety-five percent ninety-six percent
the heart will completely recover
however at the time it takes about two
weeks or three weeks but in in between
within these two weeks you have to treat
the art as well with medication against
heart failure and then the recovery will
occur in about two or three weeks and
then everything is okay again and it
doesn't always need an emotional shock
to lead to an broken heart syndrome so
to be honest we don't know whether this
is the case however if you ask the
patient with bravado noob did you have
any stress in the past they would say
yes but if this is the case in the
future we do we don't know about and
again yes violence violence domestic
violence for instance or the death of
the husband and so on is in the history
of Kurds in the history so the patient
might develop because of this stress
syndrome broken heart syndrome professor
and recent airy am racing heart or
tachycardia can be quite scary for
doctors in patients and what problems
can arise off of that it depends on the
how fast their heart is beating and if
the heart is beating 200 per minute the
patient can collapse can feel dizzy and
can come unconsciousness and it's not
always due to emotional problems that
kind of structure how diseases can lay
behind it what kind of diseases can be
made whether different diseases
genetically diseases which is in your
heart there is the feeling that
sometimes it can occur very akin this
this heart beating can occur abruptly
and the patient field is symptoms very
badly we got a viewer question from
Costa Rica nuns in E Lawrenson he's 57
years old and he says when he watched
the world cup finals his heartbeat well
his heart was beating very very fast to
tachycardia and he was sweating and he
had some chest pain is this dangerous
first of all I would say this is normal
because it was so exciting the World
Championship but on the other hand I'm
little worried about the chest pain he's
complaining off and it could be that
indeed doing the heart is beating faster
he gots problems with the coronary
artery so with the blood flow in the
india in the heart so i would strongly
recommend this patient to go to the
doctor and he would check for instance
by an exercise arrested by treadmill at
ez c g so we can find out whether this
is psychologically in fact or just
really a heart attack but many patients
have problems with their doctors
actually because the doctors don't take
this kind of problem seriously and and
they just sex you just blame it on
emotional stress like the world finals
and so what can the patient do about
this now can this happen at all that's a
pity I would say you should change your
doctor alright that's the route clear
our ball but i but I a doctor thinking
like this why are they thinking that
well they don't listen to the patient
what this where they're telling you and
if they would listen the history and
what the patient tells the doctor he
would say well this could be really a
heart attack or coronary artery disease
rather than just obscurati psychological
effect or trauma and you as a
cardiologist I mean you're dealing with
heart disease is not so much with
emotional problems but how can you
distinguish between emotional problems
and structural heart disease well I make
a so-called exclusion procedure so what
I do is just to check whether this
patient has an odd janak disease or not
and I do this very carefully and
yeah this is advised to all doctors to
do this before you you answer and say
well dear patient you don't have an
ergogenic disease rather than a
psychological or emotional effect some
some effects are there if you listen to
the patient and he tells me that he has
never know no zest for life anymore he
doesn't play guitar any longer he
doesn't meet with friends he doesn't
read newspapers these are hints these
are factors which leads to a psycho
emotional stress situation and so you
have again see well maybe this the
patient needs other help rather than
organic yeah and adaptive rule out
structural heart disease you see a
special kind of treatment for emotional
heart disease or is it always site etc
care if the patient is in deep
depression well this is psychiatric
asked and you have to check and see
whether they do there's good clinic good
medication and and other therapeutic
possibilities however if the patient is
it would set a little bit anxiety you
can just by having physical activity
making exercise running it improves your
mood immediately so encouraged and
increase your quality of life so I
encourage the patient otouto to make
fuzzy activity so it's always a teamwork
between cardiologists and psychiatrists
professionalism thanks so much for being
with us in the studio today thank
you